sure so I mean at its core wayfinder is
a online character based action
role-playing game for you to play with
your friends old and new so we have a
lot of different content for people
that's like smaller scale with three
player content larger open World areas
than Social Hub so we're an online game
it's always changing and we hope that
you can give it a shot in beta now and
then we'll come out later on nice nice
sounds great for yourself what about
your role on the project uh creative
director I'm I'm in charge of like the
narrative characters uh art nice
yeah my background's in design so I was
game director on the project for a few
years before handing that title up and I
because my background's in level design
I've always enjoyed focusing in on the
world exploration adventure yeah so we
uh have a lot of complimentary skills
nice next everyone's working together in
unison so one thing I gotta shout out to
my boy who are playing AKA Joseph this
isn't getting off so he had a couple
questions I want to ask specifically
because obviously the world looks
absolutely beautiful so will it be
expanded with new regions or are getting
more zones
yeah absolutely I mean we are going to
be leaning into Seasons as a way of sort
of telling the story almost like like
chapters and right now the current plan
is every second season we'll be adding
hopefully a new a new dungeon to the
games
every season right now we'll have a new
character so absolutely the world is
planned to grow starting nice and modest
with our players
yeah we're trying to find the balance
between adding new stuff as we go to
expand the world and also making the
previous areas interesting again and
exciting for players to
we've said from the beginning that we
wanted to build this game alongside the
community we were really active Discord
we've had incredible participation for
the tech test that we've run the betas
that we've run we've made a whole bunch
of changes already in the game in terms
of like movement combat feel UI like and
that is a direct conversation with
players like a game like this is made
based on that relationship right and so
we've been very open about that process
in terms of like building it alongside
them so it's just the start and uh like
Ryan said it's gonna change and compare
especially compared to I think some of
the games that we find out
[Music]
so this is a very real early access and
rather than trying to obsess over
getting everything like trying to
predict what we think the players we
want from the game our goal is to get a
platform for the game out there and then
to really build it and guide it based on
sentiment foreign
because you guys are talking about like
you know your Seasons you're talking
about how like you know you're ever
wanting to change everything how often
do you guys think about you know adding
different like types of like combat
classes and different like types of um
races to to the to the realm of your of
your game yeah so right now uh we're
shooting for every three months uh we'll
have a new character a new character as
just like you see here we are a
character based game so right um that'll
also come with a signature weapon and
every other season we're looking to do
that that zone so we're expanding the
world and telling the stories in the
game and outside the game um but uh the
characters will bring um brand new
abilities uh it's essentially a a class
but a fully fleshed out voice character
um that brings a lot to the table that
you can customize however you want and
just to follow up on that you know one
of the things
signature so we have any Inspirations or
anything like story
um I mean my my background was in comics
so Marvel for a lot of years
[Music]
which was a blend of fantasy and sci-fi
which also conveniently was our first
game at Airship and ended up becoming a
game like five years later
and I think for this world we wanted to
push the Sci-Fi even a little more
because I'm with every game we tried to
give it a different flavor and so
finding that like fantasy and Magic but
there's also guns and like Cool Tech it
really gives us a lot of freedom to do
whatever we want uh and then the
characters you know just having worked
on our previous project was League of
Legends RPG everyone King and we learned
a lot from Ryan
they have a lot of characters and
they're all really cool uh so just
there's just years and years of we also
a lot of us worked on the Darksiders
franchise yeah so we we've we've got
like a history of building characters
um you know honestly like for us making
a project this scale has always been a
dream it seemed unattainable because
when you pitch you know like anything
approaching an MMO to anyone it's like
too scary yeah
you're doing that you got to kind of
slide it up
by the way it's going to be an MMO
before you know it yeah and so we
started with that base and as the world
grows if they do introduce like new
cities and new overlands like we're
hoping it will really feel like we have
player housing social stuff like that so
um there will be a lot more to the game
than just comment are you are you going
to be ending up like adding like larger
scale like more difficulty dungeons as
in like more raids like more than you
know the regular player base yeah right
now we have three player three-player
Dungeons and if you go out into the
overlines there are already World bosses
you can find and summon in the world
that require participation like the
scale of like 8 10 12.
um but we definitely plan and future
once we get sort of like our standard
dungeons really dialed in to expand to
their harbors and whatever radius which
might be six or ninth years is that what
you're I'm sorry is that is that kind of
what you're kind of adding like aiming
for to be like the overall kind of like
end result like for for like end game
content because I mean I'm the MMO guy
out of probably out of everybody yeah so
that's why I wanted to make sure I was
kind of here so like where are you guys
kind of aiming for to make that like
that content for those in-game players
right now I mean the way in game
basically works is after you have gone
through all the dungeons there will be
an added like a tier sort of all the
blossoms that you can go back and
baseboard same thing for for all the
bosses in the months and I mean every
every season or two we're just gonna add
more and as the world gets bigger don't
get to get more numerous and the real
Target of all are the Hunts which are
the hot spikes yeah the Hunts will
probably be where we really Flex on that
that consequently made where we require
six or nine people
kind of like World bosses but okay and
it's all it's also important to note
that like out of hard work like she gave
like so that end game is collecting more
characters everything that we have from
all the characters behind other weapons
um those can be crafted inside the game
it's not something you have to outright
purchase you can make them so um we
incentivize players doing that because
it allows retirement growth so if you
play Someone Like
A Cedric who's a war master
um and then you're like all right well
I'm gonna try out what grade was also
warmaster you're actually Progressive in
as well and leveling that up so um it's
important that we have that as well as
like all those dungeons we're talking
about are totally repeatable because
they are randomized upon entering so we
wanted incentivize people to continue
living game and have something new and
then when we do introduce new content
down the line we can also refresh all
the content by making those Dungeons and
new events New enemies that might spawn
in there yeah I think that's a good
distinguishment to make is that when you
pick a character you're not picking a
class like the goal is not for the
player to invest into one character of
this class and just play that here at
their classes for their mechanics in the
game they're really incentivized
unlocking all the characters and then
playing them all and getting them all
into level cap leveling up multiple
weapons because there are certain
talents and abilities you unlock only by
playing multiple characters yeah so it's
really not about one character kind of
encouraging that kind of diversity of
places
you know one question I had for um again
specifically and he said obviously
seemed impactful to produce
that would kind of have that completely
impact on different impact well we are
planning on adding more mutators which
is what uses the dagger to affect your
run you enter a lost sound and we're not
exactly sure the Cadence yet because
each time we add a mutator because you
can mix and match them uh it has like a
ton of different effects so we have to
introduce
but it's definitely something we plan on
doing
and more places foreign
chests and things where you can like
affect the loot that you get from it by
the mutators that you have equipped in
your dagger things like that so we're
we're still exploring it but we want to
do it a lot more for sure
just in general like all the challenges
you get a lot of feedback at the same
time like how do you go through that
balance of maybe the original vision of
what you guys have versus okay players
may want this but does this kind of mess
with the development cycle of the game
like how does that how do you how to
find that balance to be honest we're
finding it you know probably ask us in
like six months
not a joke where it was a big mental
shift that we had to make going into I
mean really the first time we launched
the data even some of our smaller scale
closed betas if that was more feedback
than we've ever gotten on another just
prior to it being released and I think
it taught us the scale of information
for players and rather than being I
think concerned about it when we're
viewing it as something that was going
to be a challenge we actually embraced
it as an opportunity because unlike
premium game development
again and maybe you need to do Focus
tests
this gives you the chance to make the
game alongside and you can pay lip
service to that particularly like you're
doing it but really just march to view
around or you could really think this is
awesome now it kind of takes some of the
guesswork out of the development voice
because the players are telling them
so why not why not address that you
still have to maintain your coordination
at the center can you not compromise
that right but it's really not as
difficult I think as we thought to Pivot
based on playroom because it's
complimentary too how do you guys end up
like you know like taking all these
classes and all the weapons and
everything how do you guys actually like
made sure those like our balance because
you know you don't want to see like the
same people using the same classes for
everything
it's on going yeah yeah internally
everyone has opinions uh yeah we are
constantly playing the game we have uh
you know beta everyone fills out the
surveys uh we're Gathering that
information Early Access will be huge as
well it's just uh it's gonna be ongoing
like yeah we know it is and we have to
react to that kind of stuff it's like
like Ryan said we you know we feel like
we know what players want or should want
but if everyone's like hey uh guns are
the best I no one is using melee weapons
ever it's like okay like that's weird we
either need to make just ball guns or
like make the melee weapons better yeah
stuff like that it's all gonna like we
have a pretty good idea of where we
wanted to go but ultimately you know
we've already made a lot of changes over
the last four months just based directly
directed on feedback you have to learn
from a production standpoint how to tune
basically set aside time to address
feedback right yeah and that's something
that along with the game changing
yeah
I love that Synergy to the community
you know the game look absolutely
vulnerable so then I know I would be
playing with friends
so this is something that's definitely
wrong
how can we get what's the final piece
for anyone that's on the fence we would
say this is a genuine chance
there's been
lately about betas being just a
marketing effort
games
and participate yeah
and I think as people pick it up and
play it and they see what we're going
for and like this game was made because
we play these temperatures we want to
make this type of game and so like Ryan
was saying like we want those players
here to also essentially nerd out with
us and make this game alongside of us
like that's why we're doing it so um
will be free to play so there's really
no barrier to entry so you can jump in
available like three yep it's early
access would be sometime in May but um
hopefully people give us a shot and a
little one side of it we'll make
mistakes but that's what communication
is for and we'll end up making a better
game final page
yeah you know check it out like AJ said
we're really excited about building this
world and obviously it can only grow
with people in it and playing and
helping us make it better so yeah
uh you guys are I know that you guys are
on the PlayStation also on PC is there a
course platform now and in the future or
full cross platform save cross-platform
play our last beta we turned that on it
worked everyone was happy
it works yes
functionality yes yes no that is the
attendant we can't wait for people to
play across all right sounds great
thanks so much thank you absolute
pleasure thank you oh it's a way finer
thank you for a good time go check it
out it looks absolutely beautiful
the chaos